[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> IT'S THE MAN WITH THE CLOTH.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE SCAREY STORES
STILL WORK ON ME.
>> WHAT ABOUT YOU, BRANDON, DO
YOU HAVE ANY GOOD ONES?
>> MAYBE WE SHOULD TURN IN.
>> COME ON, MAN.
>> IT WOULD BE NICE TO HEAR A
STORY IF YOU HAVE ONE, BRANDON.
>> FINE.
YOU WANT TO BE SCARED?
I HAVE A STORY.
ONLY THING IS IT'S NOT A STORY.
IT'S REAL.
IT HAPPENED TO ME ABOUT TWO
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS STILL AT
THE AD AGENCY.
I GOT A CALL FROM MY DAD.
>> WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> HE ASKED ME IF I COULD GET A
COFFEE WITH HIS FRIEND'S SON.
>> THAT'S NO BIG DEAL, RIGHT?
>> A 22-YEAR-OLD RECENT COLLEGE
GRAD.
AND AN EXPIRING FILMMAKER.
>> SO DID YOU DO IT?
YEP.
HIS NAME WAS CONOR.
AND HE HAD A LOT TO SAY.
>> WHAT'S AT THE MOVIES THESE
DAYS?
EVERYTHING IS A REBOOT.
HOLLYWOOD HAS NO ORIGINAL IDEAS.
IT'S ALWAYS GUY MEETS GIRL.
THAT'S WHY WHEN I MAKE MY MOVIES
THINGS WILL BE DIFFERENT, TRUST
ME.
>> RIGHT.
>> SO HIS TAKE WAS THAT BASIC?
>> EXACTLY.
BUT LIKE HE WAS THE FIRST PERSON
WHO EVER SAID IT.
>> HOW LONG WERE YOU THERE?
>> TWO AND A HALF HOURS.
LITERALLY TO BREAK DOWN THE
STATE OF THE INDUSTRY.
>> CGI WHEN IS EVERYTHING BASED
ON VIDEO GAME OR ROLLER COASTER.
HELLO "ACCESS HOLLYWOOD" CAN YOU
MAKE SOMETHING ABOUT REAL
PAPERS.
THAT'S WHY I WOULD SAY A WARNING
THIS MOVIE MIGHT MAKE YOU THINK.
I REALLY LIKE TALKING TO YOU.
>> HOLD ON THIS IS CRAZY, HE HAD
A BACK UP PLAN.
>> NO, JUST FILM.
>> DID HE HAVE ANY IDEAS?
LIKE DID HE TELL YOU WHAT HIS
MOVIES WOULD BE ABOUT?
>> OH, YEAH, HE HAD AN IDEA.
>> DUDE, THIS SHOULD BE A MOVIE.
JUST LIKE YOU AND ME TALKING
ABOUT MOVIES.
THAT'S WHAT REAL LIFE IS.
>> THEN YOU LEFT, RIGHT?
>> I TRIED.
>> BUT THAT'S WHEN HE SAID IT.
>> HEY, COOL IF I GET YOUR
NUMBER?
>> STOP.
>> DID HE EVER CALL YOU?
>> NO.
NO, NO, NO.
HE TEXTED.
3D, DUDE, HURTS MY EYES.
SO EXPENSIVE.
THAT FEELS LIKE TV IS THE NEW
MOVIES.
HAPPY THANKSGIVING BROTHER.
>> THERE ARE SO MANY.
>> BUT HE HAS TO LEAVE YOU ALONE
EVENTUALLY.
HE CAN'T TEXT YOU AND PICK YOUR
BRAIN FOREVER?
>> NO, HE STAYS WITH ME.
UNLESS I CAN INTRODUCE HIM TO
SOMEONE ELSE HE CAN TALK TO.
THAT'S HOW THE CURSE WORKS.
>> YOU ARE NOT GOING TO DO THAT,
RIGHT?
>> I'M SO SORRY.
>> NO.
>> HEY, MAN, ERIC, REMEMBER MY
PODCAST?
WE TALK ABOUT CLASSIC HOLLYWOOD
FILM.
>> NO!